ronaldo lopez going to the mound and
last time out he threw very well against
the astros one hit and two innings there
were scoreless innings he's getting a
start
and hopefully gets his curb all over the
plate because if he establishes both the
curve and the slider to get them over
early then he can use the fastball to
help wipe them out
strike to arise
and there is his third hit of the
doubleheader just incredible the pitch
before he was frustrated that he missed
it and he almost went through so if he
can miss bats like that
[Applause]
certainly in better shape
as he throws on a rise and the ball gets
away
[Applause]
well down the line a rise of booking for
third
and he's in there standing up
fly to right ball carrying toward the
gap
and caught by sheets on the warning drag
arrives scoring easily
but he has some problems with anything
off speed
peter got him this is out of his sweet
spot because a fastball is up
he throws it by him he's got that
uppercut swing
3-2 is called strike three oh cruz
didn't like it he turns to allen porter
jose barrios goes to the mount on for
his 19th start
looking for his fourth loss his era just
a touch below three and a half
2-2 curveball and there it was for
strike three coming in
to garcia
change up struck him out back-to-back
strikeouts to open the game so two down
for abreu
jose lights this ball up center field
gordon back at the track and the wall
he's got no room we are tied
jose is starting to heat it up and this
is more like the jose we're used to
seeing you make a mistake on him it
doesn't matter where it is and he makes
you pay the price here comes mitch
garber his first action since june 1.
[Music]
a drive to left and deep
vaughn back welcome back
mitch garber looks like he's trying to
hold back a smile that's got to feel
good after missing so much time going
through what he went through and
took a first pitch fastball said that's
not what i was looking for got a
breaking ball and
drove it all the ballpark and
i'm smiling up here in the booth you
know he's smiling big inside that's a
that's a big moment for him the guy
almost dropped afterward
throw coming into second base and they
got him oh garcia squalling out
gymnastically
to make the tag on gordon
zach thomas with a really good throw i
mean the call by chris guccione a great
tag by liuri yes sir
knew he took strike three a high slider
and two down
tough guy to strike out but this time he
just got out guests
jam
shot and simmons
across the kirilov went away i think it
depends on the situation yeah
[Applause]
and
that's been a good aim for burrillos
he can pick and choose what was better
breaking two of abreu's bats or striking
out good ones
garber now has 117 at bats and nine home
runs that's
really really good not quite on the pace
home run pace he had two years ago
but still notable and impressive
he's so strong he's able to do that he's
just trying to get the barrel to it
a drive to left center field back again
he has done it again
mitch garver with two at bats and two
home runs
after spending nearly two months on the
injured list absolutely incredible good
for him what a swing
what a ball game
what a huge add-on run everything about
it just
makes you feel pretty good
foster gets knocked down and i believe
that was caught on the fly the throw
made anyway and you hope matt foster's
okay he
got knocked down to the deck by that
hotline drive
on the ground back to foster on the turn
this is garcia and it's 1-4-3
this has got to be the only inning in
baseball that has a 1-6 line drive and a
1-4-3 double play
it's just got to be now the difference
is it's been all year
and that's
going to be the everlasting memory of
gavin sheets against burrills at least
tonight thinking about his change-up and
it's been good he's had a good feel for
it and you can see why he's throwing it
more
in this ball game
and that's pretty much the pitch that
struck him out the first time wasn't it
yeah started on the plate almost
identical location
dashes that ball right center field to
the warning track it goes and it's gone
bring him home it's a 3-2 score
johan brought his own plane
towering fly ball his ninth home run
he's now driven in 42 and it puts the
socks
within one run gonna pitch him very
carefully right here make sure you
execute got him two hits two solo home
runs over six
razor sharp innings
and a 3-2 twins lead
first base side that is through on a
two-strike hit for brian goodwin and now
the tying run is at first base moving to
90 pitches for barrio
so andrew's going to first base two on
nobody out in the seventh inning for the
sox and it's gavin sheets coming to the
plate
watching the rookie sheets
lights it up
deep right field
everybody go home
first walk off for gavin sheets
and the socks are winners and a thriller
[Applause]
the first fastball he saw hittable all
night long and he hit it out
he hit it way out can't teach
and that's power and gavin sheets has
power
that one 96 on the inner half and
barrios
you got to be able to tell when it left
the bat that that one is gone he was
hoping against hope and the white sox
salvage a split and walk off a starting
pitcher for the first time in 13
seasons